I have to go with a godfather mr. Al  Pacino when he kills the Chief of Police  oh man there's so many there's so many  this year even Goodfellas Paper Moon  Chitty Chitty Bang Bang  I only Davis and dad and it worked my  favorite movie of all time is network  I'm just mad as hell and I'm not gonna  take it anymore it was just a revelation  you think I'm funny the gum a clown I  think that seems amazing No - what -  payment girls and music smoke quite  christopher plummer singing I fell in  love and I'm in love them ever since and  the movies having a hard day's night and  my sister nudging me because I was  singing too loud along who along with  the songs the first time I saw it is he  giving plain I think you go and send  they're kidding planed on in and out  Marlon Brando will cost changed  everything that was kind of the  beginning for me of my love affair with  movies and me wanting to be a part of  that Wonder